Hey,
this is bill burr.
This is actually an intro before the intro to the podcast.
This is not the official podcast at this point.
Um,
I was on the road and,
uh,
I recorded the podcast on Thursday.
I did it into my iPhone and my iPhone wasn't synced up to my computer and I'm
too much of a fucking moron to be able to figure out how to deal with that.
So I had to fly back,
give it to my tech guy.
So I just,
now it's fine.
I just wanted to let you know that that's what it is because in five seconds
you're going to hear me talking about,
hey,
it's Thursday.
Look at me doing it all fucking early.
All right,
so that's the,
that's the reason for that.
Before you send me your emails,
all right,
go.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's built birds.
The Monday morning podcast from Monday,
July 16th,
2012 a recording at this week on my iPhone.
I'm on the road,
so I wasn't going to bring my mixer and all that other shit.
Um,
got a big week.
I'm actually recording this on a Thursday before I do my show.
So if something amazing happened,
like,
uh,
somebody very important died,
or if that asteroid hit the fucking planet,
that's because,
uh,
and I'm not addressing it.
It's not like I'm doing some hipster thing trying to act like I don't notice
it's Thursday here.
And,
uh,
I'm in Boston right now.
The friendly confines I've been behind enemy lines since 1995.
So back here in Boston and I figured what better time to do a podcast with a
fellow Boston sports fan.
Um,
Dave Portnoy's is my guests this week.
I feel like I have a real show here by the way.
Uh,
he saw the creator,
yeah,
the creator of Barstool sports.com which,
uh,
is so big now that I've,
I've heard it's now in New York,
Philly,
well,
New York's version of Barstool.
Obviously they're not talking Boston sports,
but,
uh,
before we get into this,
it's,
it's like a,
you know,
his,
his website is,
you know,
all things Boston and then it just shoots off from there from political stuff
to,
uh,
the smoke show of the week.
Right?
The hot shoe.
Pretty much anything that we feel like talking about it.
We have the Boston version of New York,
Philly College version,
but it's a,
it's almost like a guy gossip site if you want to write that way,
but geared towards,
let me ask you this,
because you know,
everybody can get a bunch of hits and that type of Shit on,
uh,
on the Internet,
you know,
but like to actually make money off of the Internet.
That's what I want to do.
All right out of the gate was to congratulate you that you actually tried.
And you know,
there's like major movie studios trying to figure out how to fucking make money
on the internet because everybody like pirates,
they're,
uh,
their movies and all that type of stuff.
So congratulations dude.
Welcome to the world of making money and not really technically having a job.
Yeah,
no,
it's not a bad place to be.
It's not a bad place to be and it's a,
it was a long Brian,
but we're here now.
What,
how,
how long,
how long has it been since you started doing,
school's been around for like seven years.
Started as a newspaper.
So it was,
you know,
you see the racks and improper Bostonian,
all that crap.
We were just a free gambling rag,
four pages,
black and white.
You see you started off giving people picks and stuff like that.
It was,
yeah,
it was sorta like that.
I mean,
I was like,
uh,
I met,
I was a degenerate gambler,
so I hated my job.
Nice.
Tried to move to Vegas,
get a job.
Well I W I,
I wait,
wait,
wait.
How bad did the gambling get?
We like one of those guys like,
oh,
it's five hour energy on the way to your phone on the way to Foxwoods.
No,
no.
I was never really big Foxwoods guy.
Much more sports.
You can't get in trouble so much at Foxwoods because he needed the money in your
hand.
You can get into trouble and much more with like sports because they'll give you
a credit.
But I mean,
I used to gamble a lot,
hated my job.
How far in did you get?
Like how much you make in a week and how much did you owe?
I mean,
I,
well this will be all relative,
but I mean I,
I've been down 30,
40 grand before.
That's a shit done.
30,
40 grand.
Yeah.
Are they like knocking on your door at that point?
Well,
you know what,
you have relationships.
My Guy who I've gone through,
my,
uh,
he'll love this part and he talking about,
but I've been going through him since college,
so I,
and it gradually,
you know,
like I did.
Fortunately you don't go through him anymore.
Right?
Just in case there's any problems.
I mean,
I was still mutual acquaintances,
but you see each other around the holidays,
you get to be such a degenerate and you get to be so loose.
Like I never win.
Never.
I mean,
I gambled since I've been alive,
I've probably collected two weeks and 30 years.
So it's like I,
you know,
I'm always going to lose.
So if I lose,
it's now to the point.
If I lost,
let's just throw a number.
If I lost 20 units,
I only have to pay a 10.
I get unbelievable discounts and it's never knock on your door.
You always knows I'm going to pay.
Like most of it worked here.
So it's never been like,
dude,
I never had the heart for it.
I long time ago in like the late eighties,
the Patriots sucked.
I forget what year,
but they was supposed to be good.
I think it was 89 and I wasn't,
you know,
I'd spent all my money on season tickets and uh,
and they just kept losing.
So I was like,
fuck this,
I'm going to,
I'm going to win some money back.
So they will losing the everybody and the buffalo bills came to town and this is
89.
So it was before they were the run and gun and everybody knew but,
but the,
but this was the fucking team before they did.
And like the bills always sucked between Oj and the running gun.
They just,
you know,
they had a couple of decent years so you know,
I buried in,
which was 50 bucks in my life or something like that.
I buried them.
And so I think Miami and they both,
uh,
and I,
the Patriots in Miami and they both didn't come through when I was down like 100
bucks.
I was making like one 75 a week and that was enough for me.
I did it once.
I think the greatest thing that ever happened to me is I,
I didn't win the first week.
Like,
did you win the first week?
No.
Most people generally do when no,
I just,
you know,
I just had the disease.
It's like I love doing it.
I know.
Luckily for me I haven't done it and it's all probably,
actually,
this is how I rationalize in my brain.
I don't think it would have done barstool if I didn't have that.
Like gene,
because there's so much risk with what we do.
Even now,
like concerts,
concerts or it's like stock market type shit.
It's like,
you know,
that's how we make a lot of our money.
We do these like basically raised for college kids.
Get those blackout party.
Exactly.
So we'll rent out buildings and you know,
we're basically pet on kids buying the tickets.
Like we're laying out tens of thousands of dollars before we do it open.
Tell,
tell the listeners a little bit about that because I didn't know about those.
I know you did all the talking,
the stuff about sports and all that type of stuff.
So you,
you host these things.
A blackout Pongo parties we started gives you shit,
right?
Yeah.
We get shit from everybody.
We're like enemy number one of Boston and lately moving,
I mean somehow we've ended up,
I mean the calls from 2020 we were on inside edition with that thing.
Who's the guy who's the gay guy with the short blonde hair?
Good looking guy.
Anderson Cooper,
Anderson Cooper.
He,
they called.
I mean,
it's all about the Blacko parties for,
even though everyone's kind of doing similar stuff.
But these are Raves,
I'm going to take it or no,
if he's gay and not,
I'm not trying to out that guy in the product.
No,
I think he's,
no,
I think he is.
He,
I dunno.
No,
he's out.
He outdid himself.
Oh he did?
Yeah.
Okay.
So you've maybe used the Thursday excuse.
No,
he's,
you may want to research it and taste.
You don't have them now and it makes sense.
He's got great half always looks gay,
guys always have great,
no,
my wife thinks he's the hottest guy,
but I'm 99% sure that he's said he's gay.
And if he has such a classic podcast moment,
we don't even know and I'm going to go with it.
It's like it's fucking fact.
Well there's nothing I got nothing you can sue me for.
So it would allegedly,
who gives a fuck either put my reputation on it and no matter what,
even if he hasn't said,
I'm pretty sure he is.
But I think you said it,
but it's your podcast,
not mine.
So,
I mean,
but I think he is gay.
Um,
hey everyone.
Have you ever walked into the post office and said,
you know what,
I don't think I ever want to come here again.
Not that I hate the postal industry,
not that I hate the people that work here,
not even that I eight postcards or something else,
whatever.
Um,
would it be great if you could take the post office and bring it into your own
apartment?
Well,
fortunately there's a way you can do it.
stamps.com everybody.
Um,
basically you get your post office in your apartment.
If you're a fan of this podcast,
you've heard of this a zillion times.
This is a zillion and one.
Um,
anything that you can do at the post office you can do right now from your desk
in your apartment,
in your house,
in your shanti to little town in haiti@astamps.com.
You can buy and print official US postage for any letter or package using your
own computer and printer.
Um,
and unlike the post office stamps.com never closes.
So you can get postage whenever you need 24 seven basically you can print legal,
postage and a,
they give you a little scale and like I always say,
you know,
you can wear a hat if you want to,
but that's not included.
You get a little scale,
you can wait packages.
You can do all this in the nude,
in your own house.
I love it.
I use it,
I endorse it and that's it.
Right now use my last name bur bur are for this special offer.
No risk trial plus $110 bonus offer includes a digital scale and up to $55 in
free postage.
Don't wait,
act now.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the radio microphone at the top of the homepage and type in Burra,
B u r r that stamps.com enter bur we're getting all the advertising out of the
way.
Here we go.
amazon.com would you like to help this podcast and help the wounded warrior
project share?
We all would.
How do we do it,
bill?
Well,
you go to [inaudible] dot com you click on the podcast page and on the right
hand side you'll see the Amazon link.
You'll see the banner I should say,
and uh,
you just click on that and then go buy something on Amazon if you want.
That's saying you have to,
and they'll kick a percentage to me,
I take 10% of that and I give it to the wounded warriors project.
Actually,
at this point,
I'm kicking 10% of all the advertising to that project because why wouldn't you?
Why wouldn't ya?
Are you an American?
Well,
there you go.
Specifically of an American from the United States before anybody gets a little,
a little fancy with the geography.
You know people in Canada,
they are American.
They all live in North America.
What about people in Honduras?
Hey,
what about your mother?
All right,
get back to me with that one.
All right.
The last one.
Game.
fly.com everybody.
Do you like to play video games while you pretend to listen to the person years
allegedly in love with?
Wouldn't it be wonderful if you had 8,000 games to choose from and a 15 day free
trial,
15 days free trial game,
fly.com/bill burr.
Go on there.
You got access to 8,000 games.
Play into your Damn Psalms.
Fall off and then you can say,
you know what?
I'm good.
I tried all your games.
It's fantastic.
You're a Gamer.
That's the place you want to go.
gamefly.com/bill Berg.
Click on the a.
What do they go?
What do they got?
A little game player.
I don't want you to do.
Just go there and buy something that makes me look good.
All right,
have a nice week.
I'm glad we got that cleared up.
I don't even remember.
Now I'm off track what I was talking about.
You're talking about to a blackout.
So basically what we do with the blackouts,
um,
I'm going to guess if you didn't know that Anderson Cooper wasn't cared,
that you don't really know what like Edm music is either.
Do you,
you met Edm dance music?
You know,
only because it was on the cover of rolling stone.
Did recently just that,
that danger mouse not danger about sia dead.
Dead Mouse.
A dead mouse.
No,
I didn't always dead.
Mt.
Five Mt.
Five dead.
My five cause I was saying that my five,
my girls going,
I think it's dead mouse and they use this a five is like an s it where's the
mouse set?
I'm not going to pass judgment because two years ago I didn't know what it was.
But now like now I'm in that scene,
I'm I,
that's what we do.
So it's basically,
as far as I can tell,
it's house music with lasers and lights and shit bouncing off kids eyes.
That's what it is.
So it's old school,
like just,
you know,
kids are doing drugs fucked up out of their mind.
And those are the parties we do.
Now.
I'm not saying it well that that's if,
if Mayor Menino heard me say that,
he'd be like here knocking on my door.
But so we do these parties,
we don't supply any of the stuff.
But the lasers,
the lights,
the hardcore music.
And is that element,
well it's,
it's a rave.
I mean it's a rave.
It's a frigging rife.
That's really what it is.
But it's not just us,
it's what college kids do now.
No,
I actually saw some of the,
some of the video of some of the girls and stuff like that.
If I was a younger man that would be the place I would go,
whether I liked that music or not.
And um,
you actually had like some fun,
eventually we will get to sports on this.
Guys,
I know you had some fall out though.
Like you,
you did some,
like on your website you had some sort of a,
um,
some sort of a joke or whatever and they uh,
that a rape joke and then you went on TV.
I got to tell you,
dude,
that took balls,
man.
Like you sticking up for your joke like that.
Like I would have stuck up for my joke,
but I would have done it with a little more tech.
I'll have a link to it on my,
uh,
for podcast listeners.
She was just
Lisa Guerra.
Yeah,
man.
She came in,
she's the girl who wasn't close to Joe.
She's been in playboy by the way.
And used to do the weather girl for sports,
for CBS sports.
That Lisa Greer,
she's gorgeous.
Yeah,
well she was,
but anyways,
the joke was,
look at me,
I'm getting price.
No,
I listen,
I call it as a C.
I mean,
I know she wouldn't look at me,
but whatever.
Um,
point is,
we had a,
there was a story in Europe,
Australia where a guy got accused of rape and was acquitted in his defense was,
she was where the judge greed with the defense.
He was wearing skinny jeans and there's no way he could've gotten the jeans off
without her consent because they were skinny jeans.
So that got him off.
That got him off.
So that was the story.
So are our take on it.
And it was the same take as we do with everything.
I mean,
we make fun of everybody was,
it came out in the story that she was a size six.
And so I said,
who cares about the rape side of things aside sick should never be wearing
skinny jeans.
You gotta be like,
Oh,
that's that big.
Yeah.
Well,
for skinny jeans.
Yeah.
I think you gotta be a zero or a two for a skinny jeans.
Um,
and I don't like skinny plus a fat girl.
You're saying,
and skinny jeans.
That's what I was saying the problem.
But they were like,
well the,
maybe that's why she,
they couldn't get him off.
Exactly.
And that's how we got off.
And then I took a step further and said,
who cares?
But that you actually,
if you're going to wear skinny jeans,
you probably deserve to be raped anyway.
So it was actually a fat joke.
Yeah,
that's exactly what actually affects exactly what it was.
I get
it.
So you go,
and so,
so anyway,
Dave goes on this show,
you'll see in the clip,
this girl goes right at you.
It's just like,
you know,
you think rape jokes are funny or something.
You were like,
somehow she was saying,
you think that joke is funny and you're like,
yes,
I do.
And then she,
then she tried to,
to cook you,
she tried to spin it and be like,
oh,
so you find reg funny.
You're like,
no,
I don't,
but I,
I did.
She goes,
well then I don't think you understand how offensive that joke is.
And then you're like,
well evidently I don't and I totally got what you were saying.
You was like,
at least what I think he was saying.
Well you're basically saying like,
like I would equate it to like seeing an old lady fall down a flight of stairs
in real life.
Not fucking funny.
Horrific.
Okay.
In a will Ferrell movie.
Right.
Hilarious.
And cause because it's so horrific.
Right.
All right,
so you actually did a like a roundabout like fat,
like sort of a fashion joke.
You sort of making it like go on like a,
that's basically ladies,
you know,
if you're a size six don't try to slam your fat ass into a by no means we're
condoning condoning rate.
And that's what everyone was twisted on us in.
But it was funny though,
but you didn't even explain it to her.
You just,
you just answered her questions and didn't try to enlighten her at all.
And that's when I watched the clip.
I was just like Jesus Christ.
Cause I w I would have been like,
look,
the joke was about this and then I would have backed out saying,
you know,
it's not my problem if people don't get my jokes,
I,
that's the way I would have handled it.
You just were like you,
you were like fucking all over north and screams.
You know what it came across it.
And here's the weird thing.
A lot of people think that clip made me look like an asshole.
And I remember people being like,
fuck,
I would think that a bunch of people think that you're a piece of shit out
exactly like this,
this fuck,
uh,
you know,
my mother in law sit and watch and you know,
channel four,
it's like,
Oh shit,
son in laws condones rape,
like what's going on?
But the thing about it,
what you just said,
that they probably an inside edition showed 30 seconds to me talk.
And I was in there for an hour and a half and I mean,
at one point I thought we were going to fight each other.
Dude,
I got to tell you that when you're getting interviewed,
the longer it goes,
that's like the first 48 where at some point in the interview you have to be
like,
am I being charged with anything because if not I'm going to leave or if I am I
want a lawyer.
But the longer you talk that's the same thing doing like standup specials.
Like I remember back in the day,
uh,
the first time I got to,
I got a half hour on comedy central.
They were like,
uh,
you know it's,
you know,
it's going to be 22 minutes cause they have,
they have eight minutes of commercials and a half hours.
So they wanted us to,
they were like bare minimum.
We need at least 28 minutes.
So I did 28 minutes on the nose.
Other guys would go over,
cause the way I looked at it,
I have no power over how they're going to edit this cause it's,
so I'm going to give them a little extra footage as I can.
And what ended up happening was they took a whole joke.
They just took the whole bit out.
I love the bit,
but I only lost,
it was only one thing to be upset about.
So I think when you get into those,
those interviews,
uh,
like further down the line you should be like,
you know,
it takes them an hour and a half to ask you about a fucking rave and one joke
and we're all over the map and work dumb idiots.
I mean they came to our office,
this camera crew and were like serving him tea and crumpets.
Oh you like crack
a little joke thing to we're buddies with these people.
That's one of the first things you learned that was not your friend.
No,
no,
but we were,
we were rolling out the red carpet.
Like they were friendly.
His house.
Super Nice.
Great.
What you're doing with your website.
It's really must be great,
you know,
like meeting young people who are doing things.
But the second that interview ended,
I knew,
I knew that she was going to be,
I mean there was,
I and I met the camera guy who also did a 2020 thing that we just did.
And even he says like it was one of the more contentious interviews and they're
built to be contagious because it was,
it was that exchange,
that type of tension the whole time with this lady at the second you sat down,
you felt she was already,
I mean we said stuff like she's,
I mean I forget the exchange we had,
there was some exchanges where it was like,
she's like,
well,
I'm a feminist.
Like,
well I saw you naked in playboy,
so I don't think the Fed,
you know,
they think you're a feminist and it was that type of exchange.
Oh my God,
they're going to release this on DVD and I see the library,
Hey,
I would pay five grand cash for the full interview.
I actually think it would make me look great because they cut up like what
you're talking about.
She didn't have any of the back contents.
I asked her a hundred times like,
did you read the blog?
You're just saying I can don't rape.
Do you even know what it's about?
She couldn't answer it.
You know,
she asked me,
do I actually think at the end of the day to use that overlies expression that
they love having a guest like you?
Cause at the end I'm going to use it again.
The end of the day they want people to watch and if they have an interview like
you,
yeah,
I think there's that weird push pull thing where they're acting like they're
completely outraged.
But they're totally psyched that your being what they think is,
is an asshole.
Right.
And I'm an easy target and I'm probably someone like you.
And then you were sitting there and a tank top.
Well that,
that's my,
that's my army gear.
Like if Rand's,
I'm wearing now,
but if I show up to a professional interview in a purple tank top similar to
this,
and it's a little more outrageous than when I wear that means I know you don't
like me across.
I'm gonna try to make a,
not a mockery,
but it's like my mental,
I know I'm about to meet,
be made into an asshole.
So you like that.
If you're going to try and screw me,
I'm not putting on a suit and tie.
Right,
exactly.
I'm not going to try.
I already know you're going to make me look like a jerk.
That's actually jerking.
Hilarious.
That's the acid you dress.
You know what they'd say as a comedian,
you're supposed to dress to the level of the room.
You know what I mean?
Like if you're going to do like,
you know some a room,
you don't come in their dress like a bum and then you know if,
if you're doing some hellhole you can dress it down.
But I always feel like you know,
you,
you know,
you at least one a in a hell.
Rome have some sort of moat between you and the animals.
So if you have some sort of,
I'm in show business shiny shirt on that,
that can kind of help tell you like,
I don't know the whole backstory of that,
but all I know when I watched that I was just like,
uh,
you know,
that's a lot of comedians and friends of mine,
Opie and Anthony Show,
I should send him that clip.
Like if they haven't seen it,
like I think they would get a kick
out of,
I'm not saying they can donate one way or the other,
cause I'm not trying to get anybody to drag it on the ship.
But just the to to the way you did that and there was no like you didn't cause
I,
like I said,
I would have tried to explain the joke.
I didn't blink.
She fucking don't face the right back out.
It was,
it was real.
It was funny.
So I'm see my face actually,
and when I rewatch it,
like I almost grind my teeth.
I knew it was coming and was like,
I just can't ring up to art.
Don't back down right here.
Just go right back out her.
Well,
it's going to be interesting as you do more and more of those interviews since
I'll be looking now for the tank top.
He's got an Izod,
he kind of likes this guy.
Maybe the thing so,
well now that we're,
we're uh,
I didn't,
can we even like,
like we haven't really even talked sports.
I got to tell you about the most depressing thing that I've heard as a Boston
sports fan is like,
I was excited that Dwight Howard was possibly going to go to Brooklyn.
And My,
my whole thing is anybody but the fucking Lakers,
like,
because I just feel like they are better at the free agency game and they got,
they have the city that the dude's want to play in.
All right.
They got better whether they got,
we got basically we have humidity,
we have the winter and we have racist.
La has better weather,
celebrity ass and racist.
You know,
cause I always tried to have like all the racists are in Boston.
Like,
you know,
all you gotta do is just see the LAPD greatest hits and you can kind of see a
through line.
Um,
but I mean out here it really is like fucking that.
That's why it made me cringe.
Like when I,
when I watched the Bruins loose at that overtime goal and those assholes wrote
that meet had shit on Twitter.
And I'm like,
do you realize that's actually affecting the Celtics ability?
Probably.
Could you,
could you keep that as a big story?
Yeah,
it was brutal.
I think I,
but honestly with that shit,
I think,
I think maybe your Lala land buy lists because I don't even care about the
Lakers.
I'm so the heat right now or like the,
the just my eye,
I've sent her an expansion franchise titles.
I would have rather the heat.
It's the Lakers,
the Lakers,
Lakers heat in the finals this past year,
I route 100% of the Lakers.
Not even a question in my mind.
That's how much I hate Miami.
I think that's the general consensus.
Uh,
35.
Do you remember Lakers,
Celtics and the agent?
No.
I remember that.
You've let go of that yet?
No,
I haven't let go of it.
I haven't let go of it because there was even there when we had the Lakers
Celtics.
I know that's nine when they call fucking 12 files on us and five and you know,
I know,
I know.
Listen,
I was there.
I,
I know.
But then again,
this whole ray Allen thing now too,
it's Lebron.
I they're my least fit.
Lebron's my least favorite human on earth in the heat or right now,
my least favorite team on earth.
Oh,
you so you still hate Lebron spies and why?
I just eat,
I hate everything about just the fact they want,
but well,
it,
I'm fascinated.
This is really fucking hard for me to talk about now because he wants so it
steals a lot
of the shit that I had gone.
But before you're going to talk about,
oh no,
it's all the reason that I hated it in a more like he's never won,
but he's been called all those whole life.
I hate that we charge is fucking 20 grand to go to his birthday party.
You know,
I hate how he twit something like did he send you like an invite and then I read
about it,
the off speed on the Internet,
on the Internet.
Um,
all the shit he does.
I mean,
it just,
everything about him drives me Berserk.
Now granted,
the fact that you used to choke in the clutch and all that shit,
I mean,
it's hard to talk about.
I know you just,
you literally as you were telling me that he was unwinding a fucking paperclip.
Don't want to tell you something.
You gotta let that Shit Go.
It's tough.
What about the range and older?
How old are you?
I'm 44.
All right,
so you got me by a little bit.
Yeah,
I got you by a lot,
dude.
You learn a lot in the next nine years where you know what it is,
is something about hitting 40.
Well,
you're coming down the back stretch and you're like,
dude,
if I'm lucky,
um,
this is mid life.
You know,
that's fucking 40 forties,
80,
right?
4,400 4,488.
The way I drink,
forget about it.
It's over.
So there's something where you just kind of get to a point of like,
am I going to be this angry?
I'm not saying you're angry,
but like am I on,
am I going to be like this?
Uh,
I,
there's a certain point I won't let it go too well,
but I've gone to that.
I Hate Lebron.
Nobody is cornered me on Lebron.
I haven't talked about him at all since you want to use to talk about him every
day?
I've just pretended it didn't exist after they won,
but then you brought him up in the La thing.
I'm saying if I lived in La,
I'm sure I would hate the Lakers more because you're from here and you're out
with all those people.
But now that that there might be some truth to that,
but I think,
I think the general consensus right now for people living around here is is the
heat and then I,
like you said right now and go in there,
just makes it a million times worse.
Well,
I look at Ray Allen like,
look,
we brought him here to do a job.
He did it.
Okay.
The guy was total class act and in the end he saw the other shoe was going to
drop,
I felt and he didn't want to go out like that.
And it's,
I dunno,
the outlet,
what they offered them.
You're,
you're,
you've been soft.
You've been softened up I think by the La Sunshine.
Other foot,
other foot drop.
Huh?
I just look,
I think it's one of those things where you,
you feel like someone is slowly breaking up with you and you just say,
you know what,
rather than go through another two years of this shit,
I'm going to leave.
Uh,
I,
I did my thing here.
I just,
you know what it is,
the thing about,
uh,
athletes is you always see the shit that they do,
but the owners for the most part in the shit that goes behind the scenes,
those guys are faceless.
You know,
they're like the bankers.
No,
I mad as I am about the fucking bankers.
I can't put one face on anybody of who the fuck did this to this economy.
And I feel a lot of times that like,
like guys,
they just,
you know,
you're just,
you're up.
You're out there hanging out to dry eye.
Ray Allen was rail in nothing but a class act in Boston right up until he left.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I look at like the has to be a fucking reason why he did that.
No,
I,
yeah,
he mom comes to the game.
Wholesome Guy,
not as selfish guy.
Well,
no,
I think he is a little bit of a selfish guy.
I think that while we're learning,
well I think the reasons they're saying it and come back is he was insulted by
how hard they went after cagey,
but not him.
He was insulted that they weren't building the offense a little bit more around
them.
I mean selfish,
nothing.
I don't think he said that.
He didn't use those words insulted.
He just said,
I felt there was a feeling right now what it's going through as the Boston
sports blender and by the time it comes out the other fucking side and we'll all
be like,
he said,
fuck thoughts.
But no,
he said in the thing like,
my heart's always in Boston.
I don't care what you fucking do.
How many teams are in the Mba?
26 I don't know.
30 30 yeah.
You picked the one that you can't go to.
You have just picked another one.
Like that's,
I don't look,
there are fucking expansion franchise.
I don't even dignify the heat as like,
I haven't been to Miami Dude.
Yeah,
but I mean Lebron.
Then he went down.
I don't care about the fame.
You think humidity is bad here and then you got fucking hurricanes and then half
the fucking cities you're going to get into a Goddamn fucking gun fight if you
go to it and then,
then you go out to Miami beach for all these rich guys are and it's all these
creepy fucking guys in 66 years old dress,
head to toe and Linden was 10 year old checks.
Broaden that show.
Talking about that.
I don't care about,
I don't think she was,
I don't care about the fans.
It's all Lebron.
I fucking hate Lebron.
I don't want him to win the fact he's going there and hit the big three.
I hate,
I hate fostered.
I hate all they complain about everything.
Every other like the Pacers series,
all they did was say the pace who's taking cheap shots versus,
and there were mugging the pacers in the middle of it.
Do we have any other topic?
That's what I think Dan based fixed.
Oh,
so do I.
I thought for the longest time I said they were fixed and then they fucking came
on.
I saw like Paul Versey right now,
dude,
I called it,
um,
the fucking,
you know,
they end up having like a mob dup ref.
Like if at the very least the thing that I can say is like they,
it is an unbelievably inconsistently officiate a game.
Like you have a watch go like a baseball game and like the strike zone is like
what the fuck?
Right.
But it's what the fuck?
The whole,
the whole game.
Okay.
So by the time you get up,
second time,
maybe third time he kinda got,
okay,
this guy's calling them really fucking low or he's calling that outside thing.
I don't know if it's the way he's standing,
but it's consistent.
Like when I became convinced that it was fixed,
I went to the Celtics Utah game,
the one where Gardner had a twisted,
his knee messed up his need for that season and I was watching the game and I
swear to God,
watch that tape.
There are moments where you can literally take somebody's head off,
no call.
And then like five minutes later you even look at a guy,
there's a file and then to that knee that you pulling on the reins,
letting it go upon a that is,
that is totally,
yeah,
that's shaving points.
Yeah.
Bluechip Timmy.
Yeah,
and I mean obviously the Celtics heat,
not to keep harping on it,
but the call,
they didn't call and Rondo,
I mean really changed the whole series at the end the game too.
Oh,
and then Wade went down.
They call,
I mean there was a dunk or was it,
I mean it from Celtics with 45 seconds or would have been up to,
to down to with 45 seconds.
Set the defense.
Bad Memories,
bad memories,
the whole thing.
Like I said,
I walked it out on my mind.
I just got to look,
I'm not worried about the Miami Heat and the too,
I hope like,
I just don't want the Lakers,
first of all the Lakers count of Ba Championship as,
as you're worried about like the total franchise record.
You know what?
And you know what he'd really is do is I sit in la and there's the sports show.
It is the worst fucking sports show on TV and always comes on after the Lakers
games.
Like just when I was like in New York,
I used to always watch the Yankees root against them and I watched the Lakers,
I root against the Lakers and at the end of the fucking a Lakers game,
this is show it's Michael Cooper.
Uh,
uh,
what,
what's his face?
Reggie Miller's sister Cheryl and this,
this Asian dude and it is the worst fucking sports show.
They're trying to be like edgy.
Like when the Celtics got knocked out by the heat,
Michael Cooper came on,
he had these yellows,
giant silly sunglasses.
He had these giant green ones on and he's like,
I'm wearing these and I'm taking him off to show that the Celtic season is over
and some stupid stuff like that.
And like I would love to tell that guy one day it's like,
this is going to break your heart.
Michael.
I know you think that you are part of the Celtics Lakers rivalry,
but no Boston fan has nightmares about Michael Cooper.
They have nightmares about worthy magic.
Kareem.
Those gave us nightmares in the 80s but all,
when I think of Michael Cooper,
I think of a guy he can suck,
but he was a guy that sucks.
Sucks.
Who?
Who does socks?
Always socks.
That's all I think of Michael Cooper.
I think of a guy who thought for half a second he could block Dr j and that
dunk.
He was like,
I can do it.
Oh no I can't.
And he got dunked on.
So I think maybe that's what it is.
That's why my hatred of the was so ridiculous and then tone down because it's
where you live.
Yeah.
And I go to sports bars and New York wasn't as bad because they could actually
talk the game after they gave you shit.
La is really bad because it never gets beyond like,
you know,
Celtics a bitches,
you guys suck.
Go Lakers MVP.
Like it never goes into actually talking to the game where like with Yankee
fans,
those guys to talk baseball,
I'll give that up to them.
They know the game,
they can talk it and uh,
I just,
it drives me fucking nuts.
You're going to be interviewing you listen,
venting.
You got Lakers,
you got la like in your,
in your brain.
I don't think.
I think if you pull people around here right now,
nine out of 10 if you could.
That's really interesting.
I,
I actually believe it now.
So the way to ask the question I guess is if the,
he played the Lakers and the finals this past year,
who would you root for it?
We put it on the blog.
It was almost universal.
He,
I mean,
Lakers people want the Lakers.
You don't want to,
because Colby already had his titles.
These,
there's nothing when a guy wins his first,
like when Peyton manning one is for,
it's like once you win one,
you can't ever take it back.
You know what?
They don't hate Lebron.
No,
I don't.
He didn't,
he didn't say,
Ooh,
maybe I'm going to come to Boston.
He didn't the guy,
look,
I think the guy like,
uh,
he had,
he had something that he had to get over.
He had to get overtaken the shot at the end of the end of the,
uh,
end of the game and I felt during the Celtic series he took that shot at the end
of regulation and like gain five or six against six.
He destroyed us in game five.
I forgot what game was.
He took it and he missed and my body goes see fucking us by mile.
Yeah,
I thought he climbed it off the rent.
But my thing is is he had the balls to test like a breakthrough.
You got to,
and you know,
we didn't go in,
but he,
he did it.
And then for the rest of that,
you know,
that championship run,
the guy didn't,
she didn't believe it.
The Lebron podcasts buddy.
I mean that's the show me.
He didn't put some on the back on his back.
He had the balls to take the last shot.
When people are saying he's the best player and like the history of basketball.
Now.
I'm not saying a lot of people say that.
I mean they compare them to Jordan.
You didn't say it,
but you said he had the balls.
Well,
when I watch ESPN,
I don't listen to what they say.
Like they,
they're,
their deal is the deal is to sell the game.
Yeah.
So they're all going to go skip Bayless and just say time.
It'd be say whatever.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm not saying he's not one of the greats.
Uh,
all of that ship off me three times VP before he wanted anything,
but now we want anything even.
What do they win?
I mean,
what did they,
what did they win with Cleveland?
They went to the finals.
Dude,
who cares what?
They have a list.
Do you think a Cleveland Fan can't even give him credit for going to the fucking
finals and add white to walk into Cleveland at any fancy?
What do you,
are you glad Lebron James Ever played for you?
Fuck No.
None of that's important because he left his hometown.
Treat them like dirt.
He's,
he's the Anti Christ though.
He isn't.
He's a,
I don't look,
I think he got really bad advice.
Some idiot agent goes,
you know,
be a great idea is if you make cities beg for you and then sit and talk about it
for a fucking,
like not even a half an hour
or whoever would,
I think it was like Dad,
the guy we interviewed them.
It was like his idea,
whoever the fuck was around him,
he should have got fired.
There's so many stories out there.
They didn't see that with him being just an ass.
Well,
until I got to hang out with somebody and see them being asked before I sign off
on that.
But uh,
um,
yes.
All right.
Let me ask you this.
Going around,
uh,
is uh,
another thing,
the Patriots with Bob Craft,
right?
That's our video with that.
That was your video.
He broke that video.
You broke that video,
correct?
Yeah.
That was sent to us.
Well,
I haven't revealed how that was sent to us.
A lot of people vast,
but the person who sent it ass anyways.
Yeah,
we got that video.
We got that.
Um,
we broke it the night before in the morning.
So that guy,
I was actually,
how do you feel,
not that you guy,
you guys big enough at this point where people like sports places and stuff are
coming to your sites?
Like,
like looking at it,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
stuff in our world,
in blogging world there,
there's maybe like,
there's a handful of sites that kind of all in our range,
so something gets posted on one of it's,
it will go everywhere because,
yeah,
because enough of the bigger sites I'll end up with it and then it'll,
I mean like channel seven interviewed me about it yesterday.
They came over and we got credit,
you know,
just like anything,
I'm sure with jokes even,
um,
you know,
it,
it comes a free for all for people trying to kick.
How long did it take you to go from that?
Uh,
and this is how we interviewed two.
I go all over the fucking place.
So let's go back to that new speech.
Said you were handing out that was a newspaper.
If yes,
how long did it take you?
Um,
and,
and how long did it take you to go from that to actually seeing like some sort
of like movement,
like this could actually start going?
Yeah.
You know,
it was one of those things,
we did the newspaper,
uh,
for about three years before the website.
Then the website came and it was in,
you won't be a c on the podcast,
but it's like a slight slope.
I always looked at it like it was,
you know,
the times or it's like very close to make him not having to shut down.
Even took a job because it was a full time job,
but I took another one and no money.
Yeah,
exactly.
So the Internet,
yeah.
I had to take another one.
I lasted like one day because I just couldn't do it,
but it was always a slow rape joke.
You wore a tank top,
they're like,
who is this fucking guy?
Um,
so it was always a slight growth and it just,
in my heart it was like,
it always felt like it was growing.
And then I don't know what happened.
People ask me that all the time.
Like,
when did you realize you kind of were over the hump?
And I think the number one thing that happened that I started realizing is the
more I'd go out Boston people would be like,
Hey Prez,
what's going on?
You know,
that's my nickname on the,
on the hand on the thing.
And that's what it was like,
Huh.
Maybe you know,
it's starting to work and it,
it just kind of continued.
And we've always,
as in terms of making money on the Internet,
I mean we've always been good at,
we're so small,
it's not just advertising and I'll try and fucking anything like [inaudible] and
we'll be aggressive and risk to go different areas.
So like the concert thing isn't really an internet thing where less at the
riskiest thing you'd say that you've done.
Yeah,
probably other than starting it.
Like we in value investing a decent amount to start it just to buy,
look those news racks that you put in the street and to pay for the printing of
the paper.
But you know,
I had a sales background,
so I called up all the casinos and offshore.
So like at you ever heard of like party poker?
Uh,
it's one of the big online poker places.
Like when you see it on ESPN,
all the guys are wearing either party poker,
poker stars.
Like we met with those guys in Vegas.
I met a couple of Indian guys.
They just built like a frigging a computer program for it.
So we were in with them and the beginning and we had enough money to last like a
year or two.
And then I just Kinda,
people are always look,
I like the Quirky Shit.
Like I never intended to be a writer or a character on the blog.
It just Kinda just kinda developed,
which I think when people ask me,
I think that's why it's Kinda successful because there was no plan to it.
Right?
Necessarily.
It wasn't like my podcast,
I had no plan.
I just started doing them and then all of a sudden it just,
it just sorta you find your way with it.
But I at least I had like stand up to fall on.
So during those two years,
the ups and downs of it,
were you having like those nights with like your thoughts awaken you up?
Like what the fuck am I doing?
Those thoughts?
I mean,
I still have those thoughts and we did a tour last year with this guy,
Mike Posner,
who,
uh,
he's writing like Bieber songs now,
so he's doing well,
but I fucking hate them.
Like poison.
I mean,
no one was coming to see the shows.
We invested so much in it.
I thought,
I thought we were going to,
how many promoters is saying that about me?
Red handed,
fucking town.
And so two tickets.
That's how the promoter fucking fields,
that's how I felt.
And it's like,
I want to throw,
I always make it right.
This guy,
I always try and I always make it.
If ever I'm doing good right now,
you know,
it took me 20 fucking years.
But um,
back in the day,
you know,
I always,
if I ever had any sort of guarantee like Michael Jackson did with the Sullivan
family when that closed down and they made a reason,
they lost the Patriots.
Yeah.
But I mean,
it's really the city of Foxborough worried that this little fucking 80 pound man
was going to somehow come there and scare of your buddy.
So the Foxboro canceled the concert and then,
uh,
well they didn't have it.
Michael Jackson is like,
well,
you were supposed to pay me whether they perform or not.
And then the Sullivan family who owned the Patriots back in the 80s had to end
up selling it and they sold norelco razor guy.
Well,
they sponsored the whole fucking toward not just here.
They had the whole Michael Jackson tour,
which isn't debacle.
Like I remember reading the finance is one of our writers,
uh,
Jerry Thornton road.
Uh,
he's best pager writer in the city.
He's awesome.
And he wrote a great piece on that whole thing.
Um,
but yeah,
the,
the promoter thing,
promoters,
I mean,
that's a tough racket.
Like we,
the thing that we switched with our black out,
we used to have to pay the talent and now we don't,
like we,
we just use kind of our name,
the bar stool.
And these kids had just rented a party.
So that takes a huge risk but deal not only that,
dealing with some of these guys,
like you don't have to name any name,
no name,
any names,
but I don't know what,
give me a bad story.
And some,
some artists comes in.
I mean it's got,
well I already named names,
but uh,
you know,
you don't seem to have a problem.
Like I usually try to,
uh,
I don't have a problem naming is,
I don't,
I feel like we're pretty straight with everybody and people fucking trash us if
they want to.
But I'll,
I won't trash anybody who doesn't deserve to be trashed.
The only reason I said him,
he does it well,
we have this entity does.
Okay,
so he goes out.
He didn't,
it's not like he's not trying to sell tickets.
He must've gone above and beyond.
No,
he didn't.
He wasn't like tweeting about the contracts,
helping to promote it.
Oh yeah.
Well then yeah,
go fuck yourself.
I show up and it's like,
we'll lose and you know,
close to six figures and you're telling me in the green room you want like
fucking prime rib and shit.
It's like,
I'm losing my shirt.
You want a hundred green towels?
It's like,
you know what,
fucking yeah,
go,
go buy some.
Yeah.
Have,
have a slice of pizza and call it a day.
I'm getting murdered here.
So it's shit like that.
But do you know,
as a performer,
you know,
like back in the day,
going in whether you sell tickets because they used to try and shoot,
I did this fucking,
it was early days of my space
and they would just slam and tours together because of like the Dane Cook thing.
Everyone was watching going,
oh my God,
he blew up on my space and they just thought it was a,
what I think of him.
Can you not say that on your,
uh,
do you think he's funny?
Yeah.
You just fucking great and that he really takes,
it takes a beat eight.
Yeah,
he took it and unnecessary fucking beating.
But they're just,
it's just,
it's part of unfortunately going into the public eye,
everybody at some point is going to get beat down.
You know,
it all,
it all just depends.
You could just take fucking,
you know,
one shot a month to the jaw for your entire career.
It's still a shot to the family.
It happens all the fucking time.
People send me,
I try not to read emails,
but I have to read them because I got to keep up on this stuff.
But like people,
you know,
if you're in the wrong mood and you don't have your defenses up,
they can trash it.
But he had a whole other fucking level.
Um,
yeah dude.
I'm like,
I'm you,
you have strong Boston Street street credibility.
Like w are our readers are officials.
And this moment though,
dude,
after this they'll probably be like that fucking Douche support and Lebron.
Fuck him.
I'll never go to another one of his shows.
It's like,
it's,
it's not something that you can,
uh,
you can,
you can really control.
So,
um,
but like back in the day when I,
when I would go to do like those studies show,
they try and try and put together this,
my space touring and then this is the whole tour.
It was just like,
well,
you got 10,000 friends.
He has 15 and you got eight so together that's like 30 something we can go play
2000 seat theaters.
Like that was the thought process and there was no link between the two?
No through line.
Like you know when they,
when they do to try to package it and sign,
can you put like a fucking bluegrass guy with a,
with a death metal band?
There was no through line.
So we would show up some of the venues we did.
Okay.
And the ones that we did and we would walk in,
nobody would say hello to us.
That'd be like one fucking bottle of Snapple in the back.
And you'd look out and there'd be these bunch of people out there and they're
like,
this is paper.
They papered the room,
which to people outside the business,
that means they gave it away.
They just a,
they gave away free tickets to try to get people to come in there and drink so
they can make some of that money back and a,
those are the nights you or even meet the fucking promoter if you do,
it's for like two seconds.
So we had a story.
All right.
We did a concert and again,
this is the same.
Poor again,
fucking a bloodbath and one of the acts,
one of the accident show up and we're in the back room in the guy who was tour
manager comes in and says they,
they said the main guy wouldn't go on stage unless I gave him four grand cash on
the spot on the fucking spot.
Why would you do that?
Exactly.
That's,
that's the stuff that I actually made a video coming home from that because I
was so mad like I,
I just took the flip cam still.
This guy hadn't,
wasn't even selling tickets.
No.
That's the thing.
We were,
let me ask you this.
What if he was selling one?
If he sold the place out,
you'll make an off suck your Dick.
I feel like I would do,
if you're selling out,
I will treat you in.
I'll still treat you good even if you aren't,
but I expect some
concession on the other end.
At what point do you know?
I will just say,
let's say a 2000 seater.
How far before the Gig do you know you're taking a bath?
Do you like this?
This motherfucker got,
some people have a lot of walk up traffic like last second.
We don't,
we haven't typically.
Occasionally we do.
Um,
you know,
we've done now enough of these where we'd been to the same places.
So if we've been at house of Blues Boston and we do a show how it sells,
there is pretty indicated of,
you know,
of how it will do across.
So it's like if we fucked up and then sell anything at loopholes,
which is 1900 and providence and then I know we're dead.
Well,
let me ask you what a manager say when you call up that client hasn't sold any
tickets yet.
The clients still wants the money.
What do they say to you?
Do they ever go,
I know he's out of his fucking mind,
but now they have a tap out.
They don't know.
They're not,
not to me,
they haven't,
um,
an agency we do.
We got,
and just dealing with stuff that we never dealt with.
And you know,
I almost like the interview.
I talked to agents like,
oh yeah,
how much,
like,
we don't negotiate what I trust you,
you trust me.
And they would just take me with like a big club,
like that old game boy for,
uh,
for whatever that system was and bashed me over the head with it.
So,
you know,
I,
I'm jaded.
I am tough to deal with now for those people because it's like,
I,
I'm so,
I'm so on edge and just ready to snap on people.
So I almost need a buffer zone.
I almost need a buffer zone.
I didn't know that we could ever have talent anymore because it's,
it just,
it was,
it drove me nuts.
And being an agent sucks too.
You gotta like,
just constantly be,
you know,
kissing her right now what the scope of you get.
You have your website and you have this,
this,
uh,
a blackout tour that you're doing.
Um,
I don't even know if we even like talked to people about Barstool sports.com and
it's just,
it's like,
no,
I said,
we have talked about it.
It's funny you did enough.
What did they say?
No,
no,
no.
I'm saying on this podcast,
we haven't talked about it at all.
And just for,
you know,
people who are new to this,
because it seems to me that,
you know,
the fact that you're in Boston then New York and Philly and now soon to be in
Chicago,
that eventually you're going to have one in all.
Uh,
yeah,
we'd like to,
uh,
you know,
our hardest thing in which I underestimated when I started this thing,
it's really hard for us to find the people,
the people.
I liked the writing.
It's a,
like we,
we've been lucky.
I shouldn't say lucky.
Can People send you shift?
Always want,
we're always looking for where is that?
Cause I know like as a blah,
I talk sports a lot,
so I have a lot of sports fans and I gotta tell you,
man,
people send me some stuff and I get some funny emails and like,
people send me questions and shit and like,
like,
uh,
the,
there's some really funny people out there.
So that's what we're looking for.
Tips at Barstool,
sports.com.
Just that they want to write.
All we asked for samples.
Gips.
Yeah,
like I'm not gonna sit there.
A lot of people,
we get a lot of this like hire me.
I'm great.
Like I'm not even a reply to that.
But if you are serious just send like look at our site for a minute.
Be like this is how they write and send us a sample of what you think would
work.
If it's good I will 100% get back to you.
We're always looking for writers,
always looking for new cities.
I mean I was looking for Chicago for three years before we finally found a guy I
thought could do it and it's just one guy.
You start with like a half dozen.
We start with a half dozen.
I wish we a is one guy basically runs per city.
So you're their job requirements really to post a new blog,
which is like,
I don't know,
a paragraph or two current events type thing every from nine o'clock in the
morning to basically five at night.
I mean it's a grind.
Beats a real job,
but it's,
it's a lot of writing.
You have to come up with a paragraph of funny shit.
It's basically,
I mean we're like current events so it's will you scour the Internet looking for
weird shit,
whether it be sports or just,
you know,
I'm trying to think of a weird one of your favorite weird stories that you guys
kind of where we have so many weird ones.
Like what's,
what's the latest one that you guys do that today?
Even in Wrentham I don't like they banned American flags and rent them because
somebody complain that there were too many American flags on the 4th of July.
So they banned them totally out.
I need,
can you do that?
I guess?
I guess so.
I mean that's a pretty weird stories,
right?
So what now what if I have a Taliban flag,
there's nothing in there so we can have a bunch of those fucking home.
And she was saying that it was the,
I should clarify,
it was the Weymouth housing authority.
So it was like in I guess the,
the subsidized housing.
But I mean I could go look at this thing.
There's so many.
I mean I know there was a story about the check with the biggest tits and the
history of the world.
They were just huge black aluminum,
the saggy titties to the ground.
I mean there's literally,
that's,
that's the beauty of the Internet is whenever you think you've run out a weird
stuff,
there's,
there's always more.
We're going to be something else.
Well,
I'll give you an example of a,
I answer questions every week.
You want to,
you want to like people actually for some fucking reason,
like ask me advice.
I don't know why I like,
I can't,
I'm not good at reading out loud.
I,
I'm,
I'm a moron,
but for some reason they asked me stories.
So this is girl with interesting past.
Uh,
all right,
so I'm going to need your expert advice on something.
I'm an expert.
I've been currently,
cause I have a podcast.
I really should start doing like some sort of disclaimer before I do these
before somebody tries to sue me.
Uh,
okay.
Recently,
I moved back home after college and started seeing a girl who went to my high
school,
but who I never really talked to.
Things were going great.
She's really funny for a broad,
uh,
pretty cute,
not to mention a,
has a heightened,
say mentioned has as heightened of a sex drive is I do.
Well,
maybe that's where the problem lied.
So I was telling my high school buddies how I started seeing this girl and
thought she was a,
the bee's knees.
Um,
he just lost a range up.
that's when one of my pals said,
wait,
you know,
me and Steve and another childhood friend of mine smoked a bowl,
an Eiffel tower,
towered her in the back of a minivan a couple of years ago.
This is like one of these dirty Sanchez.
Thanks Eiffel Tower.
I don't know what an Eiffel Tower do you not?
Let me try to guess.
Let's see.
The Eiffel Tower.
It's when you,
you,
uh,
you build an Eiffel tower with an erector set and you stick it in her ass while
you,
uh,
where Baret it.
It's like a,
you make two dudes making the Eiffel Tower this way.
She's in the middle.
Oh,
okay.
That's right.
I think I heard that one.
Isn't that more like the London Bridge?
It may be that the Eiffel Tower.
Okay.
Anyway,
so now I have an issue,
the girl,
so basically these two guys,
they smoked a joint and they a bowl and they fucking two on wonder if that God
you are here.
Cause he's,
he said that like,
I fucking knew urban dictionary whenever,
when,
when in doubt,
I'm one of those guys.
The Internet scares me.
Um,
so now I have an issue.
The girls great.
But knowing two of my close childhood friends once penetrated her at the same
time,
uh,
kind of puts a damper on things.
He says pretty gay,
which I kind of have to go along with.
I never understood the two guys with one girl.
Oh well I,
yeah,
I've asked about this,
that,
that's sort of like a,
like if you cross swords,
I think then you become gay.
I don't think you can become gay,
but I think that you're easing engine to being gay.
Yeah,
no,
I,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm just saying this is what I look like.
Okay.
I'm going to hook up with the girl.
The only thing they could enhance that is either another girl or like,
I dunno.
Fucking good fellas playing in the backroom picks up there.
No,
I even then,
I don't want to hear Joe [inaudible] voices on fucking,
so to add another,
all you did was add another dick.
You know what?
I think it's either it's either gay or it's like you just,
it doesn't mean you have to show heterosexual that you could just fucking
hydrive.
No,
I'm firmly,
I,
I've said that I'm not a believer.
Yeah,
no,
I really don't.
I don't want it to two on one guy.
But this guy's question is this question whether he's got dumped this girl,
I think,
I think that's where we're going here.
What should I do?
Should I cut off cold Turkey?
You said bring it up.
He said it'd be the better person.
Say I have.
Fuck it.
Who Cares?
I'm no puritan.
Thanks bill.
Love your podcast.
All right.
First of all,
this girl must be fucking the shit out of this guy that he's even asking this
question or is brutally ugly,
something something going on it.
I like,
okay.
I think you already answered the question.
[inaudible] should you break up with this girl?
Look,
the honest thing is,
is if you don't give a fuck and you actually liked this girl and then I'd stay
with their personally,
just every time I would go to kiss her just picture,
you know,
it's fucking two of my friends high fiving over or doing are going to be able to
Jose Conseco fucking Mark Maguire,
the forearm smash.
Yeah.
There's,
there's no fucking way.
No,
that's one of the all time,
no brainers in the history of earth.
That would be a deal breaker.
I had a guy,
a guy wrote in a few weeks ago,
said he,
he met some girl perfect.
And you know,
gorgeous,
great personality,
funny,
all that fucking shit.
And then,
uh,
at the end he signed out that she did a little bit of porn and uh,
and he broke up with her and he felt fucking bad about it.
But I just,
it's just one of those things that would bother me a heck of a lot less than the
Eiffel tower scenario that this guy just laid out.
So what are you saying this then?
It's your,
it's your buddies.
You're what?
You're going to fucking watch a football game.
I,
it's,
you get any kind of team scores high five,
five.
You think that their model,
it's much worse when you know the people.
I think,
I mean,
porn is a job,
whatever I want for it either.
I mean,
I'm not saying I would prefer not
before I met her.
So it's like,
but if I had to choose one or the other,
no brainer,
give me the porn over the point.
Your buddies,
Eiffel Tower and a girl.
Yeah.
But you know,
some of those porn star chicks after a while,
they just so fucking like item to the lights out in their eye.
You know what I mean?
Like just something happens.
I'm not gonna say no,
but at what if you actually really loved her and you just moved away and broke
up with your buddies?
Yeah,
no,
I,
that's all it.
The get rid of them.
But how can he love,
you can't,
that's a deal breaker.
I mean for me,
I could not,
I could not do it.
That would haunt me for the rest of my name.
I gotta tell you though,
he has great friends that the fact that they told him before he got too
emotionally involved.
Uh,
I don't know.
He says he's coming out to the,
the place down the yacht club this weekend.
I'm doing this Gig of the year.
I'd like to know what it looks like when when you meet him,
how does he introduce himself on the guy with the girlfriend who got Eiffel
Tower?
Well,
cause he won't,
I've already heard this podcast so you won't know.
I Dunno.
I Dunno if he will that,
hey send me a picture and we're going to judge you if you're ugly,
you won't.
Or even if he doesn't know,
I mean he,
he may know you got the email.
Like I sent you an email about my girlfriend.
Get Eiffel Tower.
Like that would be the intro.
Yeah.
I've actually,
I've had people do that.
It gets,
it can get,
we can get weird with these things.
All right,
we got time for another one here,
right?
All right.
Uh,
did the right thing.
Basically.
You haven't seen my girl in a week.
Oh,
asking if I,
if he did the right thing.
All right,
you're a fucking champ for putting up with my four reading out loud skills here.
Uh,
all right,
Bill.
Did I do the right thing?
Basically haven't seen my girl in a week.
There's this massive outdoor party slash celebration going on in my city,
Calgary where over a million people come and basically just drink fuck in party.
That faces off for a week.
Sounds like when you're blackout a and say,
and the saying is like the one in Vegas.
What happens in Calgary?
Stand peas stays during the stampede.
All right,
here's the story.
I'm trying to hang out with my girl all day,
but she's busy.
Uh,
no problem.
She finally tells me her and her friend,
her friends left her and she's alone.
I'm watching the UFC fight,
but I decide to get into a taxi and go find her and pick her up.
Then she says,
while I'm in route that she's actually at this bar with this guy she met earlier
on.
He lost his friends too.
How convenient.
I thought she said that it was the polite thing to do to help him,
uh,
Jesus help him out,
which I never understood.
Basically,
they were out getting trashed together at this bar.
I pulled up in a taxi,
she was on the patio with his out of town,
random guy at a table and saw me and kind of drunkenly stumbled over to the
taxi,
uh,
whereby I locked the door and just told her have fun and rolled up the window
and told the taxi to leave.
Went back to the u s FC fight.
Had a great night.
Uh,
granted we aren't married,
but we,
you,
uh,
but we have been dating seriously for the past year or so.
What should I do?
Um,
are first of all,
do you think he did the right thing at that?
At that moment it's a roll the window up and drive away.
Okay.
I wouldn't last me.
I was a long story.
He,
he dated her all along.
Yeah,
he's actually somebody I was going to compliment how succinct they put this eye.
So he started at this.
How did you get from the state of Pete thing to the UFC?
You know what,
my awful reading,
you probably zoned out for half a second and that's not your fault.
He was just the Calgary stampede thing.
It's the big thing where everybody fours it up,
Fox each other.
He's at,
he's watching UFC fight at home.
His girl tells him to come down and fucking meet them and then she says,
oh,
my friends left me.
And then it goes,
oh,
I'm with this guy.
You know,
I don't even fucking remember at this point.
He's fucking friends left hand.
What I,
the thing I got from his mom once she ended up in the cab with two groups of
friends who left?
No,
no,
she was still at the bar with the guy.
Okay.
She basically was [inaudible].
She was at a bar.
She didn't get lead by a friend.
She was with her friends.
She met some hot guy and they're like,
hey,
what happens in Stan feeds,
you know,
have fun.
They fucking take off.
She asked with this fucking guy,
his friends are gone and she goes,
oh,
my friends left me here.
Come and get me Damsel in distress.
He stops watching the pay per view fight goes down to get this broad on the way
over,
she drops the bomb that she met some other guy who conveniently got left by his
friends and uh,
the fuck did she say that?
Cause she does.
I don't know.
That's what the fuck's going on.
So anyway,
so she fucking comes down.
He sees it,
says have a nice night.
Rose up the fucking window.
He saw them just sitting there.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
So I got to read it again.
I,
well,
it's,
there's so many things then why not?
Yeah,
no.
Then he did not do the right then.
Just fucking let her in the car there at the same bar.
This girl was at the bar when she called him pick me up.
He drove to the bar.
She's still at the bar sitting at the bar and hit with,
with that guy.
But it's an old white guy.
I'm going to totally fucking this fucking story.
No,
I get it.
But who fucking cares?
The guy was at the bar.
You say,
who cares?
All right,
this is good.
This is point counterpoint here.
I say he did the right fucking thing.
Why?
Because I wasn't born yesterday.
And I'm not saying you were not trying to insult you,
but like,
I'm just like,
I know what the fuck and go down in a bar.
Okay,
but why the fuck,
especially during stampede week?
Well,
you know what that means at the very least he was rubbing her pussy over a
fucking,
uh,
first slacks.
You have weird readers.
Like what if this stampede is such a big deal on such an awesome party?
Why are you sitting home at alone watching UFC in the middle of fucking stampede
week?
You're asking for this girl to do whatever to what a did you get fingered or
whatever you just said under the bar.
Like it's,
it's stampede week.
Go fucking party.
Don't sit home and watch UFC.
Yeah.
Oh,
so you're saying it's this guy's fault that he,
that he was sitting there.
They don't,
yeah,
they put a chastity belt on her and let her go out.
If that's,
listen,
no,
not even that.
I'm putting this in my shoes.
If I have a girlfriend and she goes out for a stampede week with our friends at
a bar,
says it,
you know,
whatever.
She said,
come pick me up.
Like I'm not going to be pissed if there's a dude sitting with her at the table,
like it's a fucking bar.
If she wants to,
a couple of them,
she wanted to call them.
I don't have that much faith and women.
I just know what I,
I don't know.
I just don't.
I don't,
I know what I've done.
I know what I've done with women in bars in that situation.
When they call,
my boyfriend got me up.
I think every guy after a while you've rounded third.
Yeah,
in a bar.
Yeah.
That's just a weird then then why call your boyfriend?
Well,
I mean,
look,
it ain't about her.
It's about this guy.
Let's go.
What I'm going to say.
He did the fuck.
That was a strong move.
He said,
have a nice night.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Does it vary?
At least you got to just say it's not fucking cool for you to be doing that shit
and you're going to,
it's not my fucking fault.
It's whore week and you decided to be a whore.
That means if I go to Vegas on a business trip,
that's your fault.
If you let me fucking go down there.
Honestly,
if I go to them
Vegas and I stay in my room to watch UFC when she goes out,
it's Calgary stampede week.
So there's a bunch of guys what happens out smelling like fucking oxygen coming
to town.
No Dude,
why can't he go out?
Plus it was I,
he can't go up,
but this is my thing.
My thing is is if you ask if,
if,
if it's,
I will agree with that in a little bit,
but I'll tell you this.
If it's fucking whore week,
all right,
and your,
if your girl can't survive for a week,
yeah,
you don't have a fucking relationship anymore.
You know what I mean?
I,
yeah,
no,
I put put could put your lovely wife go down in New Orleans,
walk down Bourbon Street and,
and still be a faithful woman.
She could write.
Yeah,
I hope so.
Well there you go.
Let me put this way.
I'm still not,
if I see a crew that she's going with that's like six single girls,
she's like,
hey,
we're going to fucking New Orleans or Vegas for the week and like I,
I'm not happy about that.
No,
not at all.
no,
no.
So this guy is sitting home.
This,
this is the image in my head.
Get it.
I get what you're saying.
He's a fucking idiot saying and he's like,
fuck you,
I'm going to go home and watch more UFC fine.
By the time you fuck pulled out of the parking lot,
she was probably getting real for real this time.
But you showed,
you showed her I'm going to go home,
I'm going to continue to watch it.
You know,
I think you might convince me.
I at least I like his self esteem and he's also,
he's in a relationship.
Fuck you on.
Watch the fight,
I guess.
I guess the lesson here resigned on horror night.
You have to protect your pussy.
Yeah,
you do.
Yeah.
What happened?
Was it at home,
right?
And what,
this guy's the,
what happens in stampede week or whatever he said,
stays in stampede week.
Get your ass out a little living room.
He's saying,
what should I do?
Uh,
I I think at the I and I totally,
David told you,
see your point,
but I think you know,
Eh,
you made the mistake of trust in your girl and when you can't trust someone,
which you now realize you yeah.
Can't,
it's over.
It's Michael Corleone says,
Oh,
it's over godfather part two.
So I would get out of that.
So before we wrap this up,
man,
I had a great time.
I learned about your website and all that type of stuff.
Uh,
and uh,
I'm always psyched when I see somebody who got out of the fucking Matrix,
right?
You had the balls to me that people I get,
I get it.
People read all 10 that can I do this?
Can I do that?
Like it just takes the balls to go do it.
You just do a little bit every fucking day and you somehow get there.
So before we get out of it,
I got to talk red sox because I am elated that they are,
they are tied for last place right now because all I ever wanted to do was see
when it,
once they want it fucking twice and now it's senior level.
So you have an ebb and flow,
you know,
the old guard is gone.
Now we've got to build up the new team and I'm starting to see empty seats at
the Games and I'm loving that because I wanted to go back to not singing that
douchey song during the seventh inning.
No more pink red sox hats.
And I want to be able to just walk up and go to a fucking game.
Yeah,
I don't,
I'm,
I'm not mad that there unless,
I mean I still root for him,
but I uh,
not for the same reasons you,
I don't,
I mean the,
they left just a sour taste in my mouth after last year.
The collapse,
hate Beckett.
Hate him,
like poison.
Um,
I don't even know that I can really root for him as hard as I used it,
as long as he's on the team.
Um,
I love when he said it was my day off.
You liked that?
I loved it.
Oh,
I hated that day off.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Yeah,
that's exactly what he was saying.
Fuck you to,
you know he wasn't.
Yeah,
it was,
it wasn't saying to the fence.
He was,
I don't like,
I don't know that guy.
He saying fuck you to the fucking press.
Stop sneaking around.
Follow me.
You bunch of fucking garages.
Nah,
he was,
he got scratched because it was hurt and he played golf and he makes $20 million
a year and he didn't even any won a world series force.
Who fucking cares?
You want me to do?
I do.
No,
no.
I just be all I do.
I do.
I,
all I wanted to do was see him,
what it wants to want to fucking twice and they hung up because you biggest
choke and professional sports history.
I mean,
no one will ever top deck.
So another topic,
you can lose four games in a row,
but you won't be a $215 million team with four first ballot hall of famers.
You're not just not going to be,
it's not going to happen again.
The only person who could do it again is the fucking Yankees because the other
one was a spent $20 million.
Who was the plumbing staff on that?
Which was the Yankees or the Red Sox?
The Red Sox.
Yep.
When we went it was shilling Bronson or Royal Pedro Martinez.
Low Derek Lowe and Wakefield.
Yeah.
So no,
no.
Yeah.
Wakefield was back at on that team.
No,
he was on oh seven Oh,
so then who fucking cares because you already had your one,
you don't care about your second and then it went to,
you don't care if a guy is just he,
everybody says he's an asshole.
Universal from media.
The fans,
that area,
you don't care.
It doesn't like ruining for somebody who was an asshole.
It doesn't bother you in the least.
I like bear and chicken too.
Yeah,
but,
and if I could do it in between podcasts for only Ken,
but you know what I,
you know,
I think they,
I think they fucked up last year.
I think that they,
one of the fucking problems is,
is when shit goes bad,
people don't accept the fact that shit goes bad.
Okay.
And it's one of those deals where it's not always going to be roses.
And sometimes when it goes bad,
it doesn't mean you got to fucking dismantle everybody.
Like I think what the red sox did after last year,
granted,
you got to get rid of some people who aren't fucking playing and not earning
their paychecks.
I definitely understand that.
But the fucking get rid of everybody.
It's like now you know,
everybody is not as good a FC and going to the cubs is not in a better
situation.
Tito,
I understand he was sick of the media.
He rapped at least,
but everybody who was the media was the team.
Well,
I think everybody lost by the end of it.
By then.
Everybody goes their separate ways.
It's like watching,
you know what was like,
it was like watching a great band break up.
It was like watching David Lee Roth leave fucking van Halen and then you,
I'm watching Sammy Hagar,
who's all right,
but he's not David Lee and then David Lee Roth,
when he's in Van Halen,
he's a fucking rock star.
He gets out of that thing.
He became a fucking lounge singer and I'm telling you,
I really believe that that's what's going to,
I think Tito is going to be fine,
but I just think I don't disagree with,
I mean you said,
but here's my point with the red sox.
I think these guys make so much money,
millions upon millions upon millions of dollars.
And then it bothers me when they bitch about them.
I get the media,
but guess what?
The media is what gives the information and the fence.
The fence is why you make so much money.
So just to blow it off,
like with its talent,
your talent is why you make so much money,
but it,
listen,
you can be talented at picking up trash and those guys don't make the money that
baseball,
like that's a unique,
weird talent.
Like if I could fucking fills stadiums.
Yes,
correct.
But it's no different than this early.
Another talent that doesn't make that,
it just happens.
You found something that the American public is,
I,
I really honestly think I remember reading this thing where it Ringo Starr drama
for the Beatles just in case,
you know,
I know he's fucking,
he decided when he was like 70,
71 he goes,
I'm not signing any more autographs.
I'm done.
And I remember somebody wrote like,
Sky's been sign autographs for 50 fucking years.
Somebody said,
uh,
he goes,
that's fucking bullshit.
Because the fans were the ones that made him famous.
Like the fans all got together and had a meeting and went,
okay,
which band are we going to make famous?
It's like,
isn't it more that the Beatles made music that was so fucking compelling?
You couldn't ignore it.
It's like,
I think that like that,
that whole fucking philosophy that they're the ones that they're the reasons why
make a zillion dollars.
They're not okay because I don't have the power to make Michael Jordan not make
a zillion dollars.
That guy is so fucking unbelievable that you were going to watch him.
You're going to watch Colby,
you're going to,
well actual bra.
And those guys have like,
like you're talking one,
1 million to the fucking population level talent like that.
And they,
and they,
the amount of hours and the sacrifice and all this shit that they go through and
all the guys,
they got to fucking beat out to climb to the top of that mountain.
And then the reward is,
or gs and money.
Correct.
Absolutely.
But at no point do I sit there and I go,
now Lebron,
you can make it.
I have decided me.
No,
but it is.
it's not whether you make it,
it's the collective interest.
It's without,
without the interest in baseball,
which is really Irregardless of them.
Like people love baseball.
People love sports.
People love music.
But without that demand,
you know they're going to make nothing.
And their talent is unique to what they do.
But I guess threatened to what we,
we've threatened to walk away.
Love it.
We have nothing better to do.
Right?
Like I,
I would love to fucking turn my back and different times to have turned by back
on a bunch of different sports.
And in the end of it,
I'm just alone with my thoughts.
And I have,
if it was up to me,
I would a boy called the college football until they got a real fucking playoff
system.
And that's like the thing that bothered me the most.
It's never going to happen.
I agree with you.
It's an ingrained is never gonna go away.
But that doesn't mean like,
and you take a different way.
I look at it as like they're my client in a way.
Like I,
they're,
they're being paid to entertain me like the press and part of it.
Well let me ask you this.
So now this guy is entertaining.
Yoo Hoo.
Okay.
I think the player now what responsibility you ads cause I don't think that
fans,
fans feel like I go buy a ticket and that gives me the right to dump something
in run our tests face where I would know no one would throw a drink and Ronald
test space in a bar,
right?
No I don't.
All of a sudden he has on a Jersey you feel like you can do that.
You can feel like you can yell shit about something.
Let me do this guys.
Guys say whatever you want it did.
You feel it.
You can say,
I don't think you can thump.
I don't no contact nothing.
But you can be as mean as your human completely disregard me.
Okay.
Well if I think if you think that you,
that you can go like to the point of like when somebody has a kid that was born
with some sort of a,
you know a medical problem and yellow asshole move.
But that's like the type,
that's the type of shift that that comes with that big bag of fucking money.
And my thing is what I,
what I see is that media and the fans all want to hold the athletes accountable,
but we don't,
we don't like,
but we feel like,
oh well,
well then you shouldn't have got famous.
You shouldn't have become a baseball player and I and I should be able to take
out my miserable fucking childhood on you and you shouldn't turn around and
telling you to go fuck myself thing.
You should be able to take out your miserable fucking nine to five as Keith
folks at Burger King job on him who's making 20 million to play kids.
What?
I liked that he said Burger King job because he treated whoever fucking said
whatever to him with the same amount of respect.
But that's that to me,
we look at different ways like I have no problem.
You know what?
Take that key folk.
You can say,
if someone's pay me $20 million,
I will stand up there.
You can fucking throw rocks at Man.
I don't fucking care.
You're talking a good game.
You're talking to go can't go out and do it and do it day after fucking day that
has nothing.
And here's the thing,
you're going to have to have people like you remember how you felt in that
fucking interview when that girl was,
was when you felt like you were going to fucking to your job every fucking day.
I am very fond of gain is if you're a public eye that comes with it.
Like you said,
you take it different like August face to face,
but I mean I get brutal.
I think it's really easy from where we're sitting to be like,
dude,
you know what I would do if I had that kind of dude,
I wouldn't give a fuck.
The thing about it is is once you make past a certain amount of money,
it doesn't fucking matter like how much more you have and like,
you know,
buying a bunch of shiny shit at the end of the day,
it's not going to make you,
there's a few key things that are going to make you happy in life.
And one of them is,
is peace,
inner peace and silence,
which you,
when you get to that level of fame,
okay.
You,
you don't,
you don't really have that anymore in certain fucking shitting habit.
Like,
I mean there's guys who aren't assholes back at going back to the example like
no one fucking like dirt junior doesn't get treated like Beckett does.
Beckett in going back to that example of the you like when he said fair enough,
like I like I was not looking at that,
that there was,
there are athletes that are assholes.
Okay.
All right.
Well I was kind of playing devil's advocate,
but I mean I don't think people,
I mean you look up or teases kind of Yap in the water this year,
but I mean he,
he's people loving.
There's beloved athletes,
but then there's asshole athletes and all I'm saying you're going to like the
backup on,
he was like coming off what happened last year and all the fried chicken,
all the Hoopla and all of the media he missed.
He missed a start because it was hurt and then he wouldn't golf.
To me that's just,
I don't give a fuck about anybody.
That's all he said.
I don't,
I don't think the beer or anything last year at anything to do with them
stinking.
I think everyone drinks.
I just look at it like,
you know,
this is going to be a story.
Like you're,
you're,
I mean,
he didn't know he was going to get,
he,
you know,
he got caught.
He got caught like,
like a fucking,
um,
it's like,
you know,
when somebody fakes it back injury,
I'm a data guy.
Like they were showing these insurance fraud things.
It was fucking hilarious.
This guy faked a back injury.
He was suing this insurance company and then he goes out and goes golfing in the
warmup exercise he was doing when he was on there.
It was so fucking lies is like visually I can explain this to people.
It was,
he had the club,
you know,
behind his neck on his shoulders with his hands hanging over it.
And he was doing those,
the psycho like taekwondo twists and uh,
it,
uh,
and they also showed him lifting something heavy out of his trunk.
Like,
yeah,
I think he had like know charcoal,
the barbecue,
like the guy was just live in the fucking life.
That was hilarious.
Look,
I'm not saying you,
you like how I answered the question.
I just think he did.
I think he owes the same reason why I like,
well I like,
I think a lot of people cower in front of the press.
I'm not saying where the guy was,
right or whether he was wrong.
I loved it.
I love you.
Just kept going to do it.
It's my day off.
I'll do whatever the fuck I want to like.
That taps into my,
yeah,
go fuck yourself.
I don't like having a boss.
I know.
Yeah.
He shouldn't have done that.
He got caught.
He should have owned up to it.
He should've probably handle it better,
but just as a comedian watching somebody to tell a crowd to go fuck themselves.
There's always something about that that,
that,
that does make me laugh,
but I,
this is my thing,
like,
um,
when you talk I go fuck them.
Like in an angry way.
Like the people who buy a ticket to this,
this is what I would say.
I used to always go,
you know what I love about mom and pop's places,
you know the customer's always right.
And I talked to a guy owned a place and he goes,
no,
he goes right is right.
And I was like,
you know what you are right.
And I think that if fans,
I'm generalizing,
fans should have more writers.
Right?
Okay.
Don't expect this guy we made tonight.
It can he,
he can't eat chicken and drink beer before fucking start.
But you can make fun of his kid who has fucking autism.
I mean give me a fucking break and while I paid for a ticket and that's your
fault for making it as a baseball player and I can sit here with no fucking
responsibility.
What's so fucking ever and act like a total cunt and throw a drink in your face
and not expect the guy to come in and stands and punch me in the fucking face.
Like I like with,
I agree with you.
I agree with you probably are.
I do that.
Like if,
if someone says something like that,
I had no problem in the play,
you're going to beat nick guy.
If a guy won't answer a question on why he fucking golf,
don't he was hurt.
That's a different thing for me.
But I would never,
I mean,
yeah you shouldn't there,
there,
there is a line that just normal and this is almost like it goes full circle I
guess.
I think like rationally like,
but I've done the unknown rational person.
Like you're not normal if you go to that extreme like,
hey,
you're fucking kid has autism.
That's like a fucking idiot.
Like that's just a fucking lunatic idiot that nobody should sell those racist
after the Bruins games play test,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
So that's,
we're 100% on the same page there.
I'm talking more like sometimes guys get mad when they get booted and shit.
It's like,
really no,
no,
no that,
that no that then you're being a pussy.
I'm not,
and I'm not saying the reason why I'm going so hard defendant athletes on this,
it's just because I feel like that like this side isn't present.
There's never any sort of like a fan has any sort of responsibility.
Like what about like walking up for an autograph when he's eating dinner?
I think eaten dinner is a sacred thing.
You don't do it.
I think if they're,
if they're walking down the fucking street,
that's part of the game.
But if this sitting there at dinner,
like I think people even people know that,
you know when I was in San Francisco and fuck it was in a restaurant,
Joe Montana was two tables away.
Who's fucking unreal?
And somebody asked me,
do you ask him for an autograph?
And I jokingly said I wouldn't ask screech for an autograph and he was fucking
eating.
I'm not messing with.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't fuck with me.
What am I doing?
I'm assigned my Napkin and then lose it.
I meant more on the thing I wouldn't ask Rowan is appetizers on a Napkin I'm
going to lose.
I wanted to ask either,
but I hope if I ever became that famous,
which I obviously won't,
but if you did or somebody to,
I hope I will never get mad either.
It's like that.
It's absolutely,
there's always how you would hope.
But like,
um,
I think that like the only way to truly understand what it's like cause you
know,
dude,
I mean nobody fucking bumps me when I'm going to fucking like I have like a cult
following in comedy clubs and other than that,
nobody knows who the fuck I am.
So I have this great,
I'm in,
I'm in the perfect place in this business.
I'm known enough where I can sell tickets and make a good living,
but I walk around and nobody fucks with me.
But I've been around,
you know,
with certain events where I've done standup with super fucking famous people and
dude,
it doesn't look like fun.
It looks like a,
it looks like they never look comfortable and they just want to get the fuck out
of there.
And it's one of those things where people go,
well then why the fuck did you become a musician?
Why did you do that?
And my answer to that would be like when,
when you start out,
what you think being famous is and then what it really is is for the most part
miles and miles apart.
And then when you see like,
uh,
like just from when I started,
when I started doing,
I mean,
I guess it was the fucking Internet,
but I started in [inaudible] 92 there was no cell phones with this biggest,
his fucking chair.
There was none of these cameras and film and stuff.
And like,
it's like everybody's become like the,
the spies and like,
I mean,
like that has an affect my world.
But like when I look,
I've seen guys who are like,
it's just everywhere they fucking go.
People see and they'll just come walking up to you like filming you and say
what's up to my friend?
And I think after a while,
like it's just like anything,
it just,
it just fucks with you.
It's like,
look dude,
I get it.
I totally appreciate the,
I just want to fucking chill here and,
and,
and have something to eat.
And it's one of those things that,
but for the on the fan side,
it's like,
dude,
I've been rooting for you.
You know,
I'm spending money on New Jersey.
I put money in your fucking pocket.
This is my five second window where I'm going to see you,
you know,
make this five seconds of my life.
And I think people are human and they don't let,
don't let those guys be human where every once in awhile I'm going to get so
much shit from your fucking people on the website.
No,
I mean,
you know,
I think you're doing,
you're straddling the fence both ways.
So I don't think you will get shit.
I mean I just,
and we are in that world.
I mean,
we're an internet,
so that's our living with people taking your country or a country and you should
be treated like one.
But I think sometimes,
you know,
on,
on either way,
you know,
fans booing you,
you're not fucking hidden and that,
that comes with it.
And if you cry about that,
you're a con.
But like if you go to a game and you're yelling that type of shit,
you know about people's families or you know,
other things like,
you know,
they,
they see,
then they find out like psycho fans find out like what the,
you know,
they know what the wives look back and I started harassing them in the snow.
It's all over.
There's extremes in both sides.
I mean,
and then you have athletes,
guys like Charles Barkley uniformly,
everyone says awesome.
Like daisy Buchanan's year ago,
two years ago when he was playing,
was he playing for at that point it might even been a silver,
the 76 and he was just hanging out and he was cool as hell.
And you know,
it's funny,
he didn't make a big deal out of the fact that he was Charles Barkley.
So he's the raw,
so nobody rushed him.
And I think when you come in,
you know,
with like felt ropes around you,
I think you actually build up the two we're going to go like on for an hour and
16 here.
Um,
all right.
Wrapping it up here a day.
So fucking nice to meet you.
Thanks for letting me swing by.
Here are barstool sports.com and if,
if people out there who are insane about sports and you want to start,
you want to get out of your miserable life and that fucking cubicle and I
actually write about something.
Are you always wanted to ride or whatever you think you can do it?
Where should they send it to?
Chips?
A bar stool,
sports dot.
John T,
ips at parcels,
uh,
sports.com.
Um,
uh,
that's the Monday morning podcast.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.
And uh,
that's it.
Let me shut this thing off here.